-Welcome back to the show.
And I want to thank you for
doing the Zoom interviews, too,
as well, because
you're always there for us.
-I loved it.
-I want to say, one week
from today, Monday --
next Monday,
you have the new season
of "Snowpiercer" premieres.
Right?
-That's true.
-That's a big day.
-True.
-"Snowpiercer"
premieres next Monday.
But it's also
your 40th birthday.
Happy birthday to you, buddy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Happy birthday.
-Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
-Do you have any plans
for your birthday?
I know it's odd to make plans.
-Yeah, I don't know.
I mean, we're in pre-production
for "Blindspotting," season two,
which is a show that I write.
It's on Starz.
Any "Blindspotting" people?
-Yeah, that was great.
-Yeah, so we're actually
gonna be up scouting in the Bay,
which is great for me.
I get to be home
and see my family.
Yeah, so that'll be nice.
I don't know.
I'm trying to sneak my way
into a Warriors game,
but we'll see how it goes.
-Yeah.
Where are you from?
-I'm from Oakland, California.
-Ah, Oakland.
-The show is set in Oakland,
so we're scouting
locations up there.
-I know --
This is for your 39th birthday.
You had a cake and --
Your friends got --
[ Both laugh ]
I just don't remember --
What is this photo from?
Because I don't remember
this photoshoot, but...
[ Laughter ]
Uh, I don't know what this is.
-Yes. Did some digging.
That's -- That's --
[ Laughs ]
I believe that is from
a short film that I did
not long after college.
I believe it is called --
-I believe -- it's so funny.
-I believe it is called
"Rock Hard:
The Rise and Fall
of Sexual Detergent."
[ Laughter ]
And I'm playing an I.T. guy
turned rock star.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Which is pretty much my life.
[ Laughter ]
-And who knew about this?
And who was --
-That is my friend --
Yeah, Rafael Casal,
one of my big co-conspirators.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah. And our friend, Kim.
Her sister has a bakery,
and they make incredible cakes.
And that showed up at my house.
-Well, give a quick shout-out.
Do you know the name
of the cake shop?
-Yes, Sweet Nothings.
Sweet Nothings Cake Shop.
-Sweet Nothings Cake Shop.
Shout-out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go get your cakes!
-Go get some cakes.
They put your picture on a cake.
-Yeah.
-You have good friends.
You bought a house
a few years ago.
I think we talked about this.
But recently,
"Architectural Digest"
did a whole spread
and photoshoot of your home.
Beautiful.
-Yeah.
-But you said that you only take
credit for one thing only.
-Yeah, yeah, the wallpaper
in our downstairs bathroom
is my choice.
Emmy Raver-Lampman made all
the rest of the choices.
She's a genius.
I made this one.
-Okay. Can we just --
This is a wide shot.
This is a wide shot
of the wallpaper, but...
-It's a very
Bay Area-specific wallpaper.
It's all -- It's all, like,
particular Oakland
or East Bay landmarks, really.
So, you got, like,
E-40's on there,
Mac Dre is on there,
Humpty is on there,
The Bay Bridge is on there,
Joe Montana is on there.
-Yeah.
-It also has local news anchor
Dennis Richmond is on there.
[ Laughter ]
Which is like a real --
You have to be pretty much
my age and from the Bay
to know who KTVU News anchor
Dennis Richmond is.
[ Laughter ]
It's a real deep cut.
-This is Dennis Richmond.
I don't know who --
I don't know.
But he...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He's on my bathroom wall.
-That is on your bathroom wall.
-Yeah, and we may be related.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that right?
Look at him.
-He's a stud, yeah.
-You know?
I'm trying to be like that.
-Why not?
I want to ask how everything's
going with Clipping, too.
-Good.
Yeah, we're good.
We're recording new music,
which is exciting.
-You are?
-It's super weird to, like,
record remotely
during all the --
you know, when everything
was scary and stuff.
So, it's been nice.
We actually, like,
got to get together in a studio
and start making some new stuff.
So that's been --
that's been great.
-Congrats on that.
And I've got to say,
because everything you do --
you do so many things,
but it's all quality.
It's all well-done, buddy.
So congrats on that.
-A man of your discerning taste.
-I do. Always is.
So, yeah.
Best to the gang, Clipping.
"Snowpiercer."
This next -- season three?
-Yeah, season three
is coming out.
We're shooting season four --
like, we start shooting
season four soon.
This is cra--
Do y'all watch it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Snowpiercer" is good.
It is fantastic.
-It's a little scary for me.
I can't, I can't.
-[ Laughs ]
-But, yeah, no,
it's been a wild ride, you know?
That was my first --
It was really, like,
my first TV contract I signed.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I was like, "Yeah, TV?
What's that?"
And now we're like
three seasons later.
-Really?
Because you did "Hamilton" --
-Did "Hamilton,"
and pretty soon after that,
like, I was -- like, I think
it was maybe the first thing
I auditioned for
after "Hamilton."
And then, like...
-I told you this before,
but every episode, it's a movie.
You're making, like,
tiny movies.
I mean, actually giant movies.
But hour-long movies.
-It is, like, really intense
and action-packed.
-Yeah.
What's happening this season?
-Oh, man. The --
I mean, if you remember
last season, we --
You know, Wilford's back,
and we separated the trains.
And now, like,
I'm on a pirate train.
And it's, like,
hot instead of cold.
It's a whole thing.
Look, it's a big --
-It's a big show.
-It's a big thing.
A lot happens all the time.
We're always throwing axes
and fighting death.
-Yeah.
Jennifer Connelly.
-Jennifer Connelly.
-She's fantastic.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Daveed Diggs
in "Snowpiercer."
Take a look.
♪♪
-I'm going out there.
-No, you're not. I'm going.
-Neither of you
are going anywhere.
-We can't stay here.
Ben.
Ben, do you copy?
-We are not leaving him.
-Layton, if we don't get rolling
right now, we will melt down.
-How long do you need?
-8 minutes to get up to speed,
10 to 12 minutes to run
a discharge sequence.
-Great, go.
-Whoa, whoa!
And leave you outside?
-The breach suits
have 30 minutes.
You go, you come back for me.
-We're staying here.
-Yeah, like hell I am.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Daveed Diggs.
Season three of "Snowpiercer"
premieres next Monday,
January 24th, 9:00 p.m., on TNT.
And it's his birthday!